You talked about scalar light therapy. Do you recommend adding that to rife as stated in the
question about scalar today? No, I'm saying that is the rife. So light therapy is what you're
using already. You're using a Tesla bulb which is a gas-filled bulb which is using light as your
healing source. Versus using a like a electrical stem like as everybody go into a physical therapist or
a carpractor they put these electrical pads on your body because your muscles are in spasm and
they turn it up and say okay is that good enough is that high enough and it's zapping your back and
it's helping to relax the muscles. That's electrical therapy or PEMF device where it's pulsing
electrical frequency boom boom boom boom through your tissues. These are great to help relax muscles
these are great to help decrease inflammation but they're not going to kill cancer. They're not
going to kill pathogens so electrical therapy isn't going to kill a pathogen because it's a different
wave form whereas light therapy if it's the same frequency of the pathogen it's going to kill the
pathogen. So if you're running let's say if let's say I have a virus let's say I have COVID okay and
I'm running the COVID frequencies I'm going to be helping my body kill COVID. Let's say I have cancer
and I'm going to run let's say I have a you know breast cancer and I'm running the breast cancer
frequency that's going to help my body kill breast cancer. So because it's a light frequency
tuned into the same frequency that you're trying to kill so that's the that's what's scalar
if you're using scalar energy in that in that definition of the term and again I don't like
this early using that term because it's not really defined in science but if we're going to
define it that way which which most alternative the beginning of the use of that term that's what
it was meant it's light therapy that can penetrate your tissue that's scalar energy
then that is the correct definition of that term though because it is a scientific term
companies have kind of redefined it to sell a product and I don't like that so
that's why I just don't use that term.